[Musique]
et
d'amendé moment de
delà de la perte elle s'est faite par
tous j'ai commencé à avoir des cheveux
sur mon oreiller et je me suis retiré
quelque chose qui se passe pour moi
c'était trop aussi
au delà de la chimio c'était aussi
entrer dans le vif du sujet quelques pas
parce que je savais que la chine mais
cette conséquence
la perte de cheveux symboliser quelque
part cela
j'ai accepté la maladie de manière
positive c'est important de se sentir
belle et dupont en voici peut-être que
mon âge jouent un peu dans ma façon de
voir les choses aujourd'hui je crois que
c'est important qu'il faut pas
s'enfermer
il faut pas se replier sur soi
absolument aller vers l'autre comme dans
chaque étape de sa vie il faut aller
vers l'autre audi spécialiste des idées
les membres de la famille qui sont en
passe d'être à l'écouté ça c'est
important
yoland caire